hey guys Pete here alright this is going
to be my recap and review for part 9 of
20 season 3 the return if you haven't
watched part 9 this is your spoiler
warning because it will cover everything
that happened and spoil the episode for
you however I do have a ton of other
twin peaks' videos that you can watch so
click on the link at the top and check
those out rather than just clicking away
so yeah I had kind of gotten into the
pattern of doing the top moments video
and then doing the recap and review but
this week I have to switch it up because
I got a travel day tomorrow and it was a
tough decision because there were some
moments that I really wanted to talk
about in that context but if I don't do
this one now I probably won't get it
done until the day after tomorrow and
that'll just mess things up because no
one will watch it don't forget there is
the timestamp link in the description so
you can skip the scene-by-scene if you
want to and just get into the discussion
and let's jump into it so it starts off
with evil coupe walking we can see that
this is directly after his run-in with
Rey because he still has blood all over
his shirt and whatnot he finds a red
bandanna tied to a post so we figure he
arrived where he was trying to go then
we see Gordon flying looking out the
window in the airplane cami brings him
the phone and he talks to Colonel Davis
this was the call about Briggs's body
being in Buckhorn so they decide that
they will go there and Colonel Davis
tells him to meet up with lieutenant
Cynthia Knox at the Buckhorn PD go back
and we see Eva coupe walk up and he eats
Tim Roth who is playing hutch we find
out when we heard about him back in part
2 and Chantal is there Jennifer Jason
Leigh's character and he tells them that
he needs to clean phones and a gun and
then Chantel gets ready to clean him up
and we see that he does have to loot the
bullet shot wounds too right they're
back on the plane Gordon asked Diane as
she'd mind going to Buckhorn on the way
back home she says [ __ ] you at first but
once he mentions that it might be of
interest to her because of Cooper she
says Blue Rose
or blue roze case and asked for some
more booze as a way of accepting that
she'll go along Tammy gets another call
this time from warden Murphy and he
tells Gordon that evil coupe has escaped
people coupe has the new phone and he
sends a message that says around the
dinner table conversation is lively he
then calls mr. Todd and asked if he's
done it yet referring to taking out
dougie coupe and mr. solid says no to
which evil coupe says that he'd better
have it done the next time they talk
back in his office Todd looks worried
and called in his assistant and I don't
know about anybody else but I loved this
actor I love the way that he plays this
character I mean he looked nervous all
the time back at the I don't know
hideout I guess you could say or
meeting-point
Cooper evil Cooper gets what I imagine
is a bag of weapons he also has some you
know like an ammunition case there and
he gets a kick-ass looking truck
and I don't know about anybody else but
I saw this in the periphery there and I
was like this is going to be the new
evil coupe mobile yeah he gets some
weapons and ammo from hutch and he tells
them to kill the warden warden Murphy
was in the next two days and he says he
doesn't care if it's at home at work on
the way
hutch asked him if he wants Chantelle to
play with him first and she says I'll
make him sing and he basically said he
doesn't care just take care of him and
then he'll have a double header for them
in Las Vegas
hutch tells her to give him a wetland
give the boss of wetland before he goes
and they have a pretty intense kiss
goodbye and then he tosses his phone and
tells hutch to take care of it which he
does with the shotgun and a pretty
impressive move I mean he shoots it on
the ground away a little bit away he
then go over to Las Vegas and we see the
bushnell is being questioned by the cops
while dougie and Janie II are waiting
outside to find out something for
interesting info here about dougie Jones
find out he's been working for Bushnell
for about 12 years and that he was
involved in a car
accident just before he started at Lucky
seven Bushnell says that he sometimes
has lingering effects related to that
but he says Doug he's a good employee
slow and steady after he walked out of
the room another cop pulls out a file
and we find out the dougie has no
records before 1997 no birth certificate
passport nothing tops think it might be
that he's in witness protection and one
asked the other if he saw that friend
somewhere in the government and they go
that direction on the way out Bushnell
tells dougie he can have the rest of the
day off dougie coop I should say here
Jamie says that's good she'll take him
to the doctors and he says that they
need to get working to find some answers
the next day because the kind of
wondering if they should even bother
interviewing dougie coop again they said
he doesn't really say much and sort of
like interviewing a dog and that his
wife does all the barking so they bring
a new cup of coffee so that they can
take the old one and get his prints and
DNA off the first cup we also find out
here when they come back that they were
able to lift like the spikes prints off
the palm which isn't very surprising
since they had the actual palm and they
decided to switch gears and go look into
that before they leave they tell the
prints guy defended Jones's home but he
has to do his job first so we don't
actually see them leave instead we see
dougie coupe sitting there looking at
the flag we can hear America the
Beautiful playing in the background a
woman comes in and walked by wearing red
shoes and those catch his attention
after she passes he focuses in on the
electrical outlet as his eyes pan back
across the room so we leave him there
staring at the electrical outlet it's an
interesting little scene because it
gives us a little bit of insight into
what's going on with dougie coop I mean
we don't really know what's going on but
we hear their music to see he's
responding to the flag we see that he
responds to her he's not just brain dead
I mean that's what I took away from it
back at his motel like the spike is on
the phone he's leaving a message for
eighty the message is no cigar taking
medical leave and then he takes a drink
we see the cops arrive outside and are
able to apprehend
iiq when he tries to leave without much
of an incident they have both ends block
and they remind him that they have his
palm print in fact that they have his
palm and that's that he just sort of
surrenders at the Twin Peaks Sheriff's
Department Andy and Lucy are there
they're looking at chairs online it's a
funny back and forth it's not too
stretched out it's pretty well acted
it's kind of fun all the way around I
would say she walks back and tells him
that she really loves the base chair he
says he wants the red but then he sits
for a moment comes back up and says he
can she can get the one that she wants
and then she goes ahead and buys the red
one anyways then we have a pretty
mysterious and strange scene where we
have of what we hear this woman's voice
asking who let him out then she starts
calling for Johnny and we see someone
running through the house Johnny
crashes into a wall and ends up on the
floor with a photo of a waterfall next
to him he's obviously bleeding there's
blood on the wall and the woman comes
over but we don't actually get to see
who she is then we get a surprise
appearance from his Briggs and mrs.
Briggs and Bobby had come to visit and
he says that him and the guys need to
ask her some questions she tells them
that she already knew they'd be coming
at some point major Briggs had actually
prepared her for it told her that it
would happen she says that she has
something for them and takes them to the
living room she says this is the chair
and then pops out what looks like a
little metal cylinder she gives it to
them after telling Bobby that his father
always knew his life would turn out okay
and then they go to the kitchen to have
coffee it was a really exciting reveal
there and one of many that are going to
be related to major Briggs throughout
this episode Gordon Albert Tammy and
Diane arrive at the Morgan Buckhorn
Diane lights up a cigarette right in the
waiting room there of course the
detective says hey you can't smoke here
she says it's a [ __ ] morgue and it's
another great Dian moment so she stays
there the others leave the room and she
checks her phone we saw her look at the
phone on the plane but it was locked so
there was some anticipation built up I
guess for she was trying to get a hold
of someone but if we find out that it
was actually evil coop that message that
he sent about around the dinner table
conversation is lively was actually sent
to Diane as the rest of the FBI bunch is
going down the hall we listen as they
get filled in and we learned that
Hastings lawyer has been arrested for
his wife's murder and that his secretary
was killed when her car blew up
Albert dropped some Albert love here
when he says what happens in season two
to the detective when they view the body
the detective tells us about William
Hastings blog that him and Ruth's were
researching an alternate dimension and
then Albert reads his last post today we
finally entered what we called the zone
and we met the major Albert and Cole go
out in the hall to think out loud and it
runs down like this Albert mentions that
it's the body of a 40 year old they
thought Briggs died 25 years ago in the
government of facility in the fire the
body was 25 years off as far as age goes
Cooper knew Briggs Cooper showed up in
this neck of the woods at the same time
and now Cooper is on the loose in this
neck of the woods
the coroner shows them ducky Jones's
ring that she found inside the body her
and Albert get along smashingly and they
have a little back and forth about
marbles then Cole says they need to see
and talk to William Hastings to get
ourselves a little Jerry moment he's in
the woods still wearing the same clothes
we saw him in the last time we saw him
it appears his foot is talking to him
and it says that it is not his foot he
looks amazingly high and eventually he
attacks the foot and tells it to go away
we have an officer Chad sighting in the
conference room where he's eating he
makes you know sort of a big deal in a
passive way about being asked
and following the rule that there's no
eating in the conference room
Frank pulls out the cylinder for major
Briggs and they look at it and Bobby
tells them he knows how to open it since
his dad bought one of those home before
but they have to go back outside to do
so
they go out he throws it down against
the pavement it starts making a noise
and when it stops he throws it down
again this time when he takes it back up
he's able to open Frank pulls out what
turns out to be two pieces of paper
rolled up inside one has the two peaks
printed on it with what looks like a red
Sun and a moon above each one of them
and then the symbol that was on evil
coupes ace it says 253 yards east of
jack rabbits palace has the time 253 and
to date ten one and ten to on it we find
out those are two days from when they
actually got those pieces of paper it
says to put some dirt in your pockets
before leaving jack rabbits place from
that area so it seems a little cryptic
but Bobby knows where to go because this
is a place that he went to with his dad
as a kid and he's actually the person
that named it jack rabbits palace the
second piece of paper is one of those
printouts from listening post alpha that
we saw way back and it says Cooper twice
on it whereas they look at it caught
points out that it's a reference to two
Cooper's gordon and tammy joined i in
outside while she smokes which is one of
my favorite moments
gordon is awesome and i'm not going to
go deeply into that now since a3 cap in
review but that was a great scene inside
they see Bill Hastings
Tammy asks if he's the author of the
blog the search for the zone he admits
that he is she says something about
alternate reality and he says different
dimension but that it's all real now
there was a whole lot of information
packed into this little conversation
like a lot but the gist of the whole
thing was is that him in ruse
Ruth Davenport who was the head that was
connected with the body the headless
body of major
raids in the crime scene in the very
beginning he says he was good at finding
documents so she found some information
that made them think if they went to a
certain place at a certain time
something might happen so they go and
this was a while back two weeks or so
and that's where they met major Briggs
we know it was major Briggs because he
identifies him in a lineup that she
shows him on a you know in one of those
cards so major Briggs had been hiding or
hibernating and he needed them to get
some coordinates from him from a secret
military file they came back the
Thursday prior to this you know
interview and gave him those and then
things get a little bit unclear as to
what actually happened but we know that
Ruth died someone pushed him on the
ground and asked him what his wife's
name was but we don't find out who they
are we find out that they gave the
numbers to Briggs he started to float he
said Cooper Cooper before his head
disappeared bill thought this was
beautiful and amazing and something he'd
never seen or heard of before but then
he realized Ruth was dead and it was
horrible after that after he held her he
woke up in his home after that we get
the idea that bill was pretty much
having a psychological break prison
isn't doing him very well I would say
and the events that led to him being
there are not adding up Albert pointed
this out by saying fruitcake anyone and
then we cut back to Twin Peaks there we
see Ben in Beverly are still
investigating the noise that's inside
Ben's office and the process of that
they almost embrace and then out of
nowhere then says that he can't do this
which is a surprising turn I think but
besides that they don't get down to what
the noise is and then we go to the
Roadhouse there we meet two characters
we haven't met yet they look a little
rougher the where especially the blonde
talked about losing her job at the place
serving burgers and she talks about a
wicked rash you guys and we see that
it's pretty serious when the brunette
sits down she asked if she knew that the
Zebras out again
and then at the end the blonde says have
you seen that penguin other than nine I
really don't know what what's going on
with these two after their conversation
we get a musical outro and the episode
ends alright so if you skip and
scene-by-scene welcome to the video this
is the conversation part and then a lot
of stuff happened it was sort of like
episode 7 in a way where a lot of things
went forward I think one of the big
things that I'm excited about is that
they have Cooper's prints you know Agent
Dale Cooper Sprint's will emerge out of
that cup of coffee that he touched we
also know that Janie II is planning on
take him to the doctor so dougie coupe
storyline is definitely moving forward
like the spike is apprehended which
would make for some interesting
situations when people who've told hutch
and Chantal that there was going to be a
double-header in Las Vegas so that could
mean that Ike is on the chopping block
or it could be that mr. Todd and Ike are
on the chopping block or alternately it
could be that he's still after dougie
coop and Ike the spike so definitely
some drama ton fault there the major
break stuff was just absolutely awesome
I mean he's I've said it many times
before that he's one of my favorite
characters in the original run and he's
playing a huge role even though the
actor passed away the idea that he set
this stuff up in advance is very
interesting think about the fact that he
took Bobby to a place that he used later
on as a point for them to go to and he
showed him how to open this cylinder
with full confidence that when the
cylinder was found Bobby would be there
so yeah it's really interesting and the
pieces of paper inside are also very
interesting I guess in two days time and
Twin Peaks time we'll find out what's
going on there it definitely seems like
it's probably some sort of portal or
something along those lines the number
253 comes up twice there the time is 253
and the distance from
Jackrabbits palace to the meeting point
is 253 yards which is the number that we
heard the arms evolution say and the
time when the
which happened between the real agent
Cooper and dougie Jones there's also
that there's also the fact that the rain
is now on the map so not only is
Cooper's prints going in but they're
also going to have this lead on dougie
Jones and Janie II based on the fact
that that ring shouldn't be that hard to
track I mean if nothing else is going to
be a piece of the puzzle for them to
realize that these two characters are
important and then we have the bill
Hastings stuff I mean we have big
information dumped there with his blog
the fact that he was researching
alternate dimensions and that through
his research that him and Ruth were able
to find major Briggs and that's all
really big stuff there and we know that
evil coupe is looking for numbers that
Ray obtained from his secretary who was
blown up with on that out that she had
been blown up so we have to imagine that
this is another place where evil coupe
wants to find but what's going to
actually happen there I couldn't tell
you I mean we know he's looking for what
might be the experiment the mother or
maybe it's something else entirely who
knows just a lot of good stuff happened
in this episode I mean the show keeps
surprising me in the way that it keeps
us interested by you just really have no
idea what's going to happen the title
this is the chair came out a little bit
beforehand and I was wondering what it
would be and I will wager that no one in
the entire world figured out that that
would be related to major Briggs his
wife and a chair where she's been hiding
a metal cylinder for the last 25 years
so yeah some new characters as well
hutches on the scene we find out who Tim
Roth is playing got a couple more
characters at the Roadhouse which I'm
sure will play some part going forward
and now I'm interested to hear what you
guys think a lot of Revelations Gordon
Albert and Diane we're all fantastic
again I hope that part never ends I hope
that they're involved all the way
through Tammy I thought had a pretty
good performance in this episode and
Bill Hastings his hitting I mean the
actor really destroyed that I mean it
was really good so enjoyable episode
can't wait for more let me know in the
comments what you guys think please like
the video if you enjoyed it since
to my channel and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon